yeah welcome to this video it's a
15-minute game don't down feel like
rushing too much so let's go for a
15-minute time control and e4 played
against Isis 2010 I don't think I played
him before dry is taking a style ok yeah
yeah plenty should be five normally here
this is a line that of course nowadays
has some accumulated quite a bit of
theory but it's some line that is
playable without them so many concrete
lines that you you need to know by heart
so on I can play it even as a model
efore player not risk to to be much
worse it can happen of course but it's
not like by Kim I don't know there's a
Sicilian night off where you need to
know everything on my heart mmm should
be three probably I need to go h3 at
some point but right now I think night
before I can really take yeah I think I
can take on c5 Queen d2 now he will play
night chief awesome let's prevent that
what I'd like to do is to get rid of the
bishops so I'm exchange with Queen d2
bit of age six and then maybe
most the night and play a form later
mmhmm yeah maybe he wants to go see form
but see who I always can answer with
default and I have a nice center
interesting the question is how do I
continue now i can even known yeah the
problem is i can go deform or i can take
first is the term is a term and IDM to
play air form from long castle and h4 h5
hmm not probably not let some keep it
simple this is some nice center I can
just go short castle and centralized my
pieces it's not easy for black to get
any substantial counter play here he
could try the very direct b5 now be five
before checking the night and um okay
mmm if I if I can I interest take my
daddy five isn't even a problem anyway
even if you would take the I can just
read stuff that just casts on him and
not spend too much time on easy moose v5
is even technically it's possible oh
this one okay look you looked in one on
d5 cannot really take now Queen takes
with check night f65 s terrible position
for black
I'm not sure what he's supposed to do
now Queen c7 or something Quincy 827
that's probably 95 a very annoying and
done Quincy eight don't maybe Quincy aid
yeah okay I didn't think this was
playable when it's not losing material
ameed or maybe maybe a wait wait wait I
was thinking if I've which is which is
good okay but maybe a queen e 5 assume
is even better three if five Queenie 895
a song or this is terrible Queenie five
queen bee 8kg seven or create button I
have Queen a three Queen a three
mmhmm yeah okay let's not invest much
more time Queen Queen b8 Queenie's
heaven rookie eight quid a 3 attacking
the Bishop Bishop d7 and then what maybe
five I'm not sure this is so clear
Queenie 895 is basically a winning
position I think I don't think I don't
see a move ready the alternative simple
and good was a five okay now 95 down I'd
see 7s of Fred 97 as a threat and
there's probably even g 4g 4g 5 and pin
a twin the night the problem is he
doesn't have anywhere to go let's say
placer I'll know rook c8 for instance if
i go g4 how does he prevent g5 I guess
it doesn't there's no no way to do that
age 6 h-4 i'm playing g5 next winning
the night he goes King g8 I 197 with
check and turn g5 so look see a dagger
g4 and win this is important booty fire
and once years ago almost 20 years ago
lost against this motif with g4 I was so
I remember there was a very surprised
back then okay
hmm okay Georgie Forrester it's working
it's working anyway but I also and as 94
it's also also not exactly bad see
threatening something yeah probably not
just go ahead with g45 yes it I had this
son played against me about 20 years ago
I was totally shocked about g4 was of
course a slightly different position but
I was in this diagonal King on g7 Queen
on somewhere I don't know where on the
diagonal and then G forward I couldn't
do anything against g5 had lost the
piece and I didn't consider g4 because
it was so loose on the Kings side but
then it's a it's just working in this
position likes got no way out of this I
don't don't see one at least here also
night c7 was picking up material but
this is some the clearest way
yeah Winningham it's not only the night
answer the whole position is a breaking
down black well as important idea mr. G
for g5 and numb in those are pinning
situations I think what oh no he's
moving a couple yum he he doesn't he
shouldn't take on d phone but then not
I'm not one hundred percent sure yeah
beehive be five for a three years so
simple simple and good dumb young white
is dominating in the center he is making
some moves as well so cannot really do
this quick quick analysis it's clear
that like has a problem to earn as a
problem 21 to fight against the center
at some simply bad bad pieces yeah
interesting maybe we five
yeah we're doing quite a hitting some
some pieces as well I think what what
black must avoid is the c-4 move that
freezes said the structure too much and
gives white them a dominance in the
center here he will always suffer from
the bad p7 Bishop Dwight probably has
some been taking chances on the on the
on the King even this looked so nice for
white yeah thanks for watching